but also what's remark about the images  we've seen is the breathtaking heroism  of members of a public who literally ran  towards danger not knowing what  confronted them we do know from the  statement given by the Assistant  Commissioner nil Basu that there appears  to have been a device on the suspect  members of the public didn't realize at  the time that was a hoax device and they  really are the best of us another  example of the bravery and heroism of  Audrey Londoners running towards danger  risking their own personal safety to try  and save others that always say thank  you to them on behalf all Londoners but  also because it shows the best of us